the doctor is in trouble the Stephen
King adaptation doctor sleep which
functions as a direct sequel to Stanley
Kubrick's classic for shining tanked at
the box office over Veterans Day weekend
the only thing resembling a silver
lining it wasn't alone the movie which
adapts Kings 2013 novel of the same name
arrived in theaters with a sterling
pedigree it was directed by Mike
Flanagan who is at the helm of the
excellent Gerald's game a Netflix
original which ported over another of
the Masters works to the screen King
himself gave dr. sleep a ringing
endorsement and a great many horror fans
consider the shining to be among the
greatest bright flicks of all time all
of these things consider the story of a
now adult Danny Torrance still coming to
terms with his unique powers and the
harrowing events which took place during
his childhood stay at the Overlook Hotel
was expected to clean up to the tune of
25 to 30 million dollars domestic
shockingly it came nowhere close to that
total pulling in an absolutely anemic 14
point 1 million dollars at the stateside
box office it was a disheartening
development for studio Warner Brothers
as good reviews and word-of-mouth
weren't nearly enough to prop up dr.
sleep the movie was kept out of the
weekend's top spot by Roland Emmerich's
historical drama Midway which has
received mixed to negative critical
notices and claimed victory with a 17
point five million dollar haul which
itself is not exactly impressive
considering that September's it chapter
2 underperformed pretty severely for the
studio compared with its 2017
predecessor the failure of dr. sleep
could be indicative of a trend the
beginning of the end of the King
Renaissance which has seen such
properties as the Mist
mr. Mercedes Pet Sematary and in the
tall grass successfully adapted for
screens large and small in just the last
few years a slew of additional King
adaptations are currently in the works
including television series based on the
stand and Lizzie story and feature films
based on Salem's Lot the law
walk and from a Buick 8 it should be
said that dr. sleep might have had a bit
more success if moviegoers hadn't
inexplicably decided to stay away from
the theater altogether over the weekend
a little quick math reveals that the top
two movies of Veterans Day weekend 2019
only managed about a 32 million dollar
domestic haul and when we compare and
contrast with the same weekend in recent
years differences downright i popping
consider that during the same frame in
2018 universal and illuminations
animated feature the Grinch topped the
box office with a whopping sixty seven
point six million dollar grossed more
than twice the total the dr. sleep in
Midway combined for the freddy mercury
biopic biography and during that frame
with thirty 1.2 million a respectable
total that this year's top two just
barely managed to eclipse in 2017 the
top spot went to thor ragnarok with a
fifty 7.1 million haul and the second
and third spots were filled by daddy's
home - with twenty nine point seven
million and Murder on the Orient Express
with twenty eight point seven million
it's plain to see that in each of the
last two years
audiences were all about heading out to
the multiplex over Veterans Day weekend
and this year that trend hit a brick
wall as noted by The Hollywood Reporter
even Paul - Garabedian of comScore an
analytics company which provides
marketing data to media and advertising
firms remarked that this past weekend
quote was like some weird alternative
box office universe unfortunately it was
one in which dr. sleep by most accounts
a very good film and a very worthy
sequel to The Shining found itself stuck
hopefully the flicks jaw-droppingly weak
performance will turn out to be a fluke
as year-to-date box-office revenue is
trailing significantly behind last year
despite the stunning success of flicks
like Joker which is now the most
profitable comic book movie ever an
Avengers endgame which is simply the
highest-grossing film in history with
such potential smashes such as frozen -
and Star Wars Episode nine the rise of
Skywalker still to come it's certainly
not too late for 2019 to turn it around
but as far as dr. sleep goes we're
calling the time because the patient has
no pulse check out one of our newest
videos right here Plus even more looper
about your favorite stuff are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]